breaking news overnight at least two  people are dead after gunfire  erupted on the oceanfront in virginia  beach virginia  eight people are being treated for  serious and in some cases  life-threatening injuries  police say the violence started when one  person opened fire after being  confronted by an officer  that officer who fatally shot the gunman  we've now learned has been placed on  administrative leave  this morning a second person was killed  in a separate unrelated shooting nearby  police said there was no suspect in that  shooting during the chaos another  officer was hit by a car several people  are being questioned right now so far  there have been  no arrests